here now with reaction all of this fox
news contributor Sarah Carter author of
the number one bestseller of the Russia
hoax author of the foreword to the
published volume of the Muller report
Harvard professor Alan Dershowitz
thank you all Greg let's go those are
nine powerful questions I summed them up
but you have a lot more detail well the
most important question was the last one
on May 16 2016
Muller's interviewing to replace Comey
isn't it true that you discussed with
the president in the Oval Office with
two witnesses there the reasons why the
president fired James Comey
and if the answer is yes we did discuss
it that means under the regulations
Muller was required to disqualify
himself and say I can't take their job
because he's a witness in his own case
you can't be a prosecutor and a chief
witness simultaneously so that's very
important but at the top of the list as
you saw the most important thing is how
could you investigate Russian collusion
and interference in the election without
investigating how Hillary Clinton's
campaign in the DNC paid for Russian
disinformation and fed it to the media
and the FBI to influence the election I
mean it's just astonishing to me that
there's just a passing reference to the
dossier in Mulder's 448 pages you know
professor civil liberties her important
point Greg raises a good question though
he did investigate fara of violations he
had a very broad mandate and he did
investigate let's see taxi medallions
and loan applications and you know
decades old taxes that worm paid by the
way pay your taxes and don't lie on a
loan application dumb idea but with all
of that said how do you how do you then
miss the dossier issue how do you then
miss flying to a FISA Court judge to
take away the civil liberties of not
only one individual but spy on a
presidential campaign in a multitude of
ways including lying and obtaining a
FISA warrant under premeditated false
pretenses and committing fraud because
you were warned completely that it was
on
viable well the irony is that all the
questions that Democrats want to ask him
he's not entitled to answer he can't
answer any questions involving the
investigation of President Trump or his
campaign
because that was the essence of the
report they decided there was no case
for prosecution and Justice Department
regulations and tradition say that's it
you've decided not to prosecute don't do
it Comey did don't talk about what might
have been don't say that she was sloppy
with her use of the emails and don't say
that President Trump might of ABCD
you've already said it but the irony is
the questions the Republicans want to
ask about all the issues that you and
Greg have mentioned are completely
appropriate because they're not in the
report and they are entitled to ask him
why isn't it in the report why did you
pick these people to be in the
investigation what about the Pfizer what
about the steel dossier anything that's
not in the report from peaches are you
very clear he does not have a right
answer to say I won't answer that either
no he can't say he won't answer that
he's under subpoena and if the
Republicans asked him that question even
though he's in the minority he has the
answer now if he refuses to answer the
via vote and they won't vote to hold him
in contempt because the Democrats have a
majority but he's obligated as a lawyer
an officer of the court to answer any
relevant question because he's under
oath to tell the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so I think the
Democrats I'm a Democrat I hate to see
the Democrats shoot themselves in the
foot but they box themselves in help
them Sean Hannity and professor
Dershowitz although we do we agree on so
much about Israel and the Middle East
that Sarah we'd really do but but what
really we're fighting for let's see-oh
civil liberties
you can unmask American citizens without
a warrant you can't commit a fraud on
them by the court and let me these
things also you can't do you can't start
you can't have prosecutors going in
front of Congress and explaining why
they didn't prosecute the average
American if you have the average
American businessman there's an
investigation and he's not prosecuted
Congress now is trying to establish a
precedent whereby they can call any
prosecutor and say oh you didn't charge
him why not what about this evidence
tell us about the other evidence that
undercuts the presumption of innocence
it undercuts the traditions of the
Justice Department and it undercuts the
rule of law today it's the Republicans
that are victims tomorrow it's the
Democrats the day after tomorrow it's
you and me any American can be subject
to this if the Democrats establish a
precedent allowing a prosecutor to
testify about why he didn't charge
someone with a crime I know the media
mobs you know Schiff who we know by the
way we have him on tape colluding with
Russians to get dirt on Donald Trump we
actually have the tape what are the
neethu to compromise that a naked pic
tat naked to them we have those pictures
and I know you like that professor but
Sarah as we go through this here the
professor and Greg you're raising the
best points this is really the general
feeling Republicans are salivating now
to get him in that chair oh they are
lawmakers have informed me that they're
looking forward to interviewing and
speaking with Robert Moeller I think one
question that is vitally important and
Greg and Alan both brought it up is the
fact of why didn't he expand because he
had the latitude he had the latitude to
look into all things Russia
why didn't he look into the people that
Christopher Steele allegedly got this
information from which was Russians
according to Christopher Steele a large
in part of the dossier was
disinformation planted by the Russians
so the question that I would have is
mister molar did you at all look into
the other side Christopher Steele's
contacts by the way Christopher steel is
a foreign spy did you look into those
contacts with Russians that he had that
helped feed the information into this
faulty dossier that's gonna be
significantly important all right great
job all of you
and civil liberties matter our
Constitution matters